in this video we will be studying the
wheel Felix test the wheel Felix test is
a lab test which is used for the
detection of rickettsial infections
let's first talk about the principle
involved in the wheel Felix test suppose
this is an antigen on Rickettsia and has
been found al the antigen on Rickettsia
resemble the antigens present on the
surface of Proteus bacteria suppose this
is a human who has Rickettsia infections
so he has these rickettsial antigens in
his body and his immune system will
produce many antibodies against those
antigens
now since the rickettsial antigens
resemble the Proteus antigens so these
antibodies will cross react with the
antigens present on the surface of
Proteus so to do this test we take the
blood sample from that patient and we
separate the serum from the blood and
there are two methods of doing this test
the Dube test and a slide test let's
first talk about the slide test now we
take a slide and put a drop of the serum
and next we put a drop of the Proteus
antigen onto the same slide we wait for
one minute and if agglutination occurs
this indicates that a test is positive
talking about the tube test now this
test is mainly done to detect the titer
of the antibodies into the sample of the
patient so to do this test we set up
multiple test tubes and we put the serum
of different dilutions into each test
you suppose this is the test tube with
the least diluted serum and this is the
test tube with the most diluted serum
and next we put a drop of Proteus
antigen into each of the test tube we
incubate these tests you for four to six
hours at 52 degree fifty to sixty degree
Celsius and flocculation indicates that
a test is positive
and the test you with the most diluted
serum which shows flocculation or
agglutination indicates the titer of the
antibodies present in the serum now will
Felix test has its downside also that it
has a very low sensitivity and
specificity so many new tests have come
up in place of the wheel Felix test so
this was a short video about the wheeled
Felix test I hope you find this video
informative make sure to hit the like
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for upcoming videos thank you
so much for watching this video